foreign
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today John how's
it going quantastic guys we are going to
talk today about the Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania mid credit scene when I
said in our non-spoiler review that it
felt like an SNL sketch there's a lot of
question marks to why I said that and
now while I see that there's a lot of
people who love this mid-credit scene
and there's a lot of people who really
don't like the mid credit scene as well
I want to say specifically why today we
did not really jive with this mid-credit
scene the post-credits scene good nice
clip that they played but the mid credit
scene was the one
that definitely raised some eyebrows we
just got to go into it's the first order
of business if you're here leave a like
or a dislike or a comment just engage
with the video in some way who cares how
you do it just be honest now let's dive
right into it first thing I want to say
is yes I understand I said in a
non-spoiler and I'll say it again the
context of what this med credit scene
represents and what it's setting up
totally cool in fact before this movie
came out this was a big theorized what
might be in the mid-credits scene and
sure enough it came to fruition so I was
like yeah I'm not surprised to see it
but when it played out I'm talking
specifically about how the scene is
handled that's what had me the most
concerned and what made me cringe kind
of the most when watching this film and
had some audible laughs at her screening
at the end of this movie not gonna do a
full ending explainer recap here King
gets taken down by a bunch of ants that
uh were set up really late in the film
we could take him down by a bunch of
ants and then eventually gets fully
taken down by Ant-Man and wasp who gets
like stuck in the quantum realm but
according to this mid-credits scene he's
dead he's dead because in this mid
credit scene what do we see we see Rama
Tut we see a mortise and I think it's
either like Prime gang or Scarlet
Centurion or or maybe some new futuri
king that ramata does say must upset you
that you weren't the one to kill him but
they do confirm that the exiled one is
dead now when they first start showing
up on screen I did not think it was cool
it actually read as goofy and the reason
why is this when you're seeing them
again contextually it sounds like it
would be the most awesome thing in the
world when you look at what Jonathan
Majors did in Loki season one as um he
who remains it's really effective has a
lot of presence very ominous there's a
real mood it's striking and he really
left an impression and then in Kane the
Conqueror in quantumania same thing very
different portrayal fully realize
three-dimensional character but then the
second you start cutting to these three
different Kings it doesn't feel lived in
it looks like Jonathan majors in costume
in makeup it's the first time it doesn't
feel like he's being Kang but acting I
could really feel like he's acting
that's what I meant by SNL sketch of
where you put an actor and costume and
makeup and they're doing some surface
notes of things so it feels like they're
playing versus being didn't really evoke
a mood it didn't really have a solid
tone on it it just read as cheesy and
kind of like a Sony post credit scene to
me in that regard I'm not even talking
about the second half of what happened
in this physical scene I was talking
about the introduction of this while
they're saying setting it up like oh
yeah people on Earth are beginning to
touch the Multiverse and they can
threaten all the work we've done it's
the interaction between them where I did
not feel like I was looking at three
different Kings I felt like they
definitely had Jonathan Majors film
three different times and they splice it
together it was like watching Mike Myers
and Austin Powers or Eddie Murphy and
The Nutty Professor Norbit films that's
more akin to what it felt like in that
moment than it did feeling like I'm
watching three completely different
fully realized characters and that's
where I was leading to cringe but then
they say I'm summing them all or some
[__] like that tell them what happened
John well I mean yeah then you you know
they exit this little chamber that
they're in and they go into this big
arena where there are multiple Kings
appearing you know teleporting in there
are already a ton of them surrounding
this Coliseum just cheering and hooting
and hollering and awaiting the next
phase of their plan now that the exiled
one has been vanquished so to speak it
really does continue with this weirdly
comedic sense of of either abandon or
just not that much time and effort put
into the sequence because yeah it does
feel like they just pulled a bunch of
costumes off a rack and said hey yeah
just you know do a bunch of different
things whatever comes to mind and we'll
just drop them all in and it does like
Frat Boys exactly and and the thing is
most all of them are behaving it it
almost reminded me of like watching
Space Jam a new Legacy in a way where
you have yeah just like a bunch of
copies of a person in the background
they're all just kind of like behaving
what appears to be sort of the same way
so it undercuts the variance quality and
it makes it feel like a cartoon in a way
that doesn't suit things because if you
look at the original comic book panel
there is a Whimsy to this whole Council
of Kings this Coliseum of kings and
there is I think room for quirkiness
within that but it just yeah it just
feels silly rather than quirky or you
know imposing or anything like that and
it feels like you're just in a Green's
green Warehouse rather than some
otherworldly environment or you know
some great Citadel where big
machinations are being planned out you
know the introduction in the comic is
very different to the moment that they
are definitely hearkening too because
the king that we're following in that
comic you know he's first brought pretty
much into a very dark room and he's like
who am I surrounded by who's there and
then it's revealed and there's like a
[__] ton of kings that strikes something
menacing even though it can look a
little bit silly at first it's like oh
this is a shock and versus what they do
here which just played goofy to me it
kind of reads into the issues that I had
with the last parts of this film with
King the Conqueror in the finale of this
film to me what makes Kang so
threatening is not the fact that he's a
super powered individual it's the fact
that he's a Super Brain individual he's
a highly highly intelligent that's where
a lot of his Mastery of time and being
able to navigate to get a leg up on
foreshadowing oh there's always like 50
billion steps ahead and whatnot and he's
just become so goon Reliant and in the
way this
mid-credits scene made it feel is like
okay so the threat is not really a king
or a couple of Kings it's the fact
there's a large quantity of them there
should just be like one badass like
having multiple Kings is great I think
that's a great call and there's a lot of
story you can do with that and a lot of
great things you can pull into enhance
the threat in the Menace absolutely
there should be a primary King though
not just meaning Prime I'm talking about
there should be a primary who is just
that much of a high level Evil Genius
who was truly the embodiment of the
Conqueror and that's what you or feel
threatened by not the fact that there's
a [__] ton of them and then 99 of them
feel like a bunch of dumbasses who are
just like oh yeah yeah because then you
you cut there and you're like you guys
you guys are the people we're gonna have
to be dealing with and afraid of for the
rest of the phases of this because from
the outside going into the movie it
certainly seems like this is the stage
to introduce the new big bad and I don't
mind a subversion you know I don't mind
leaving a movie going oh damn it's not
what I expected however this doesn't
give you anything new exactly to expect
and when you think back to Kevin feige
being like Oh man all the different
iterations of Jonathan Majors is going
to be amazing that could still work but
right now this doesn't you know the
three you spend time with hearing them
talk doesn't give you hope for seeing
them again in any kind of way that'll
leave an impact other than silliness and
the arena doesn't give you any other
options either to me I think a lot of
people are ending this film going it's
okay that this King the Conqueror went
down I don't agree with how he went down
oh just bottom line I just don't agree
with it all right I don't care if he's
not the main bad King
even a variance of King the conquer so
bad has been exiled he shouldn't be
going down like this you see him in he
who remains in Loki season one and then
you know he he dies you know people are
like don't worry guys don't worry he's
not the real big bad kings don't worry
the real big bad kings go and then he
dies in quantumania and if your people
are like don't worry the real big bad
kings coming and then they have this
post-credits scene which was a really
good post-credit scene Mobius has a line
in there but he's like this is him I
thought he was supposed to be like super
scary and people are laughing in the
theaters it's a funny line but it also
made me go that's how I felt about the
mid-credits scene that's what this movie
should have made me feel like he should
be I should be feeling like how Loki's
feeling in the scene but it said I'm
feeling like how Mobius is feeling in
that scene and so it's like you watch a
variance of Kang die enough it makes it
not scary anymore I'm not a fan of these
the mid credit scene I don't like the
execution of it and the idea of More
Kings coming there's still time to
improve upon it to truly make it
something menacing because some of those
Daniels you know stuff like fine I'll do
it myself in Age of Ultron that was
Goofy but this this is like
exceptionally I'm working for me
honestly yeah well there's a whole scene
of goofiness versus a shot but hey
that's just our opinion what did you
guys think did you love it did it excite
you did you think it was silly did you
think it was scary what were your
feelings on it leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe leave a like
keep a lookout for our spoiler talk that
we are doing this saturday see y'all
soon
[Music]